I'm here with Jarrod Parkes who's
a course developer at Udacity.
And Jarrod thanks so much for
talking to us today.
>> Thanks for having me.
>> We're going to talk a little bit
about student motivation in classes and
how technology can help.
So Jarrod I'll start by asking,
what kind of shaped do
you as far as motivation is concerned,
back when you were a learner in school?
So what were your experiences with
the role of motivation in education?
>> Right,
I had kind of a lucky situation.
I'm a twin, so for me a lot of my
motivation I think was always driven out
of that natural sense of competition
that I had with my twin brother, James.
But from more of what
the school was providing for
me, I think I was always
motivated by doing well.
It was always stressed that you want to
do well, so I tried to get to the top.
And for me that seemed to be enough,
at least to get me through grade school.
And then as learning got deeper and
the topics got more difficult,
I had to kind of dig.
I think more inside of
myself to find the time and
give the commitment to the topics
that you had to be successful.
>> I think you're echoing something
really important, also is that,
and there's actually
research that backs this up.
Is that early in education,
students might adopt a real focus on
some of those external motivators.
And it sounds like you're
commenting on that,
early on it was about
doing well overall.
What was your definition of doing
well back then, you remember?
>> It was very much get As in class.
My parents made it known to my brother
and I at a very early age that we had to
do well in order to be
able to get to college.
So that for me was a goal from fifth
grade and on, something like that.
And so I think there's research that
confirms that early on many students
adopt this kind of external
mindset about learning.
Which isn't inherently a bad thing
because there are powerful external
motivators out in the world.
And there are very important
reasons to learn well and do well.
But what about the tension between,
I think you mentioned this as
far as later in your career.
The tension between being motivated
by something out in the world and
being motivated by something
more internal to yourself?
>> I think that started to arise when
I got to points where I started to
question were the grades that I was
getting in class and receiving.
Truly reflective of how
I felt I was learning or
how I felt, just self worth and value.
I feel like I'm trying hard, but I dont
know if I want to commit the amount of
time it takes to get what is considered
an A, a high mark in this class.
Whereas, I feel I'm still
learning effectively and
this is just added pressure.
And so, I think intrinsically,
in and of myself,
I started to think about
why am I learning?
Why do I want to learn?
I'm actually having fun doing this.
And then I started to go after and learn
and look at topics that excited me.
Not just because somebody told me this
is what I should be interested, but
because I chose them for myself.
>> Yeah, it's interesting because
you're commenting on that.
I think a lot of students experience
that same thing where they find
something that they're very passionate
about and they end up pursuing it.
But it seems like it would be really
great if we could actually bring that
into the classroom.
At least in my opinion, there's nothing
inherent about the classroom that means
students can't be internally motivated
by something a teacher gives them.
It's that I got it from
a teacher doesn't make it, so
that I'm never going to be
personally interested in it.
It's just something happens in school
that often prevents that from arising.
So do you have any thoughts on,
either from your personal experience or
what we as educational
technology analysts can do.
To try and
create that more personal motivation,
even when we're designing
well-formed interventions.
>> I think you have to keep adaptivity
at one of the highest priorities.
I think the classroom in a lot
of ways is for a lot of people,
can be very rigid.
Because of that, when they find
something interesting, maybe they feel
silenced or they don't feel like
they can go and explore this topic.
And it's going to help them getting
hired or finishing school and
getting hired whatever.
And so being able to identify
when students have something that
they are very interested in and
then allowing them to pursue that.
And still somehow maybe tie it back to
whatever the universal message of this
class or the learning points.
That's something that I think
would be very beneficial.
>> So you're saying it would be good to
have a class where students can kind of
be given a bunch of topics to explore.
And choose which topics they'd
like to explore and when and how.
>> Mm-hm.
Yeah.
As long as they're,
I think, dense enough and
they're ones that actually would
merit a good amount of work.
And you can make those
calls as an educator.
Then yeah,
that would be a great type of class.
Those were the kind
of classes I enjoyed.
>> So, Jerry would enjoy this class, so.
You don't know this, but
that's exactly the motivating principle
behind the design of this class.
We've given the students a library of
information, such as this interview.
To explore and kind of find what's the
most interesting and pertinent to them.
>> Oh, great, yeah.
>> So, but what about the role
of technology in all this?
It seems like,
everything we've talked about so
far is kind of general to education,
the classroom as a whole.
What can technology do
specifically to help us with this?
Facilitating students' personal
motivation in these topics.
>> One thing I think about is how
technology nowadays has access to so
much information.
And because they have
access to that information,
when students are being, we're
collecting responses from students and
we're analyzing their feedback,
their answers or whatever.
We can look at those things and
make choices about or
give them recommendations about
things they may become interested in.
So the technology is what would allow us
to adapt where it may be more difficult
in a traditional classroom for
professor to give that individual
attention to each student.
I think that's something that
technology could definitely do.
>> I agree, I think that
technology also has the benefit of
making a lot of these resources
always very easily available.
That in the past, it was a case of
if I wanted to start your class
where students can
choose their own topic.
I could say, today in class,
you're going to go to the library,
find an encyclopedia, find a book and
research it yourself.
But that means that students have
15 minutes to one day to do all
the research and
find their own direction,
which is isn't really enough time.
But now we can say you have all
semester, you have the internet.
You have as much time as
you're willing to invest.
You can go in any direction you want
without ever leaving your office.
>> Right.
>> So I think that's really powerful in
making that available.
Do you have any thoughts on the role
of artificial intelligence in this?
I don't know if you have any
experience with how AI can kind of help
personalize this and if you don't,
I'll comment on it, but.
>> I don't have any deep experience, but
I think AI systems can be
the ones responsible for
finding those things that and making
those recommendations for students.
So I think that might
be a good application.
>> Yeah, a friend of mine is
actually working on a project
kind of like that that's a digital
assistant for research like this.
That if you're working for something,
it can actually connect you out to
ongoing research in the field or
similar ideas.
Or just help you kind of build
a broader knowledge of what
you're researching without having
to find everything on your own.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So and
do you have any final thoughts for
our students who might be worried about
facilitating motivation in the
technological devices that they build?
>> Yes.
My recommendation is for
any roadblocks that you ever
run into from a motivation
standpoint is to have friends.
Have people around you that support you.
I think every time that I reached
one of those blocks in my life,
that's what helped pull me through,
more than anything else.
>> That actually speaks,
I think to something we've commented
elsewhere in this class on as well.
Is that when we're building technology,
we need to be able to facilitate
interaction among students.
It's very tempting to treat my system as
the student and whatever I'm building.
But in reality, it should be the
student, their friends, their teachers,
their mentors, things like that.
And my device which is facilitating
interaction amongst all of them.
>> It's almost the intrinsic
motivation that grows out of us,
as well as the extrinsic motivators.
I think it's driven by people,
it's a people-based thing.
>> Absolutely.
Okay, well thank you so
much for talking to us today.
>> Absolutely.
>> And thanks all for watching.